[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance follow the money follow say a
hundred million dollars as it reportedly
went from russia to trump in 2014
follow the money is the most famous line
in political history said by deep throat
to bob woodward in all the president's
men and of course deep throat never
actually said it it does not mean it
wasn't true then or now then it was true
as we investigated a corrupt president's
attempt to subvert the two-party system
but he was dumb enough to leave a paper
trail of endorsed checks now it is true
as we investigate precisely how much
Russia and Donald Trump may have
subverted our 2016 election exactly six
months ago and he and his son were
perhaps dumb enough to leave a verbal
record of how Russians allegedly gave
them a hundred million dollars follow
the money
James Dodson is a golf writer an expert
the co-author of Arnold Palmer's
autobiography and over the weekend he
was featured on a sports show the
regular sports segment on the Boston
public radio station WBUR where he
recounted being invited to play golf
with Trump at Trump's new club in
Charlotte North Carolina three years ago
2014 to play with Trump and Eric Trump
and to immediately not just wonder how
Trump was financing all his golf courses
when the world of golf had never really
recovered from the 2008 recession but to
ask him how when I first met him I asked
him how he was you know this is the
journalist in me I said what are you
using to pay for these courses and he
just sort of tossed off that he had
access to a hundred million dollars
Donald Trump had quote access to unquote
a hundred million dollars for what James
Dodson knew was one of the dice iasts
investments in the world luxury golf
courses three years ago that wasn't all
of it
Dodson also says he was paired with Eric
Trump for the first nine holes so when I
got in the car with Eric as we were
setting off a said Eric whose funding I
know no banks because of the recession
the Great Recession have touched a golf
course you know no one's funding any
kind of golf construction it's dead in
the water the last four
five years you still have time to make
your guess and grab your popcorn and
this is what he said he said we don't
rely on American banks we have all the
funding we need out of Russia I said
really they said oh yeah we've got some
guys that really really love golf and
they're really invested in our programs
we just go there all the time Donald
Trump boasting to a golf writer that he
alone had access to 100 million dollars
to invest in golf courses and Eric Trump
explaining that we have all the funding
we need out of Russia and we just go
there all the time and you and I are
listening to the ground and sniffing the
wind for evidence that the reported
possible Trump Russia grand jury met in
the Eastern District of Virginia today
maybe and we're parsing the new
testimony of the former acting Attorney
General who tried to warn Trump about
the treachery of General Michael Flynn
and we're sitting through the claim that
there are anywhere from 28 to 42 names
on the FBI Trump Russia target list and
while we're expending all that energy
between them Donald and his son [ __ ]
twin number two may have told a Gulf
writer at a trump golf course my god
it's always him in some of these goddamn
golf courses that as if three years ago
the Russians gave them a hundred million
dollars follow the money
I mean at minimum if this is true Eric
Trump made his father out to be a liar
February 7th Trump tweeted I don't know
Putin have no deals in Russia is this
the part where we take him seriously but
not literally that he thinks of a
Russian funded golf course in Charlotte
not as a deal in Russia but as a deal in
North Carolina in addition to all of the
non mainstream media coverage of what
Comey is doing behind the scenes and how
many FISA warrants were granted last
year and what's up with the Russian
company alpha bank and its links to
computers inside Trump Tower and whether
hacked voting rolls we're traveling from
Moscow to the Alpha Bank computers and
then traveling from the Alpha Bank
computers to the Trump Organization
computers there is just as much media
coverage of this labyrinth of financial
connections between Trump and Russia
like the old but true cliche goes they
didn't send Al Capone to jail for
killing people they sent him to jail for
cheating
on his tax returns and oh by the way a
respected golf writer comes out in the
middle of this and says Trump and Eric
Trump told him three years ago that the
Russians gave them 100 million dollars
which might have inspired this last
Sunday morning when will the fake media
asked about the Dems dealings with
Russia and why the DNC wouldn't allow
the FBI to check their server or
investigate On January 9th I noted the
Trump could not lead the subject of
Russia alone and I predicted that it
would soon or late destroy him a week
ago he said that they so what news about
Michael Flynn getting security clearance
while Obama was president had quote
devastated everybody who was questioning
Trump's ties to the Russians quote
because you know what that kills them
that's the end of that subject less than
three days later while attacking FBI
director Comey on Twitter he added the
phony Trump Russia story was an excuse
used by the Democrats he cannot leave
Russia alone it will destroy him it is
destroying him and it will be especially
delightful if it destroys him on or
because of one of his goddamned golf
courses follow the money yeah deep
throat never actually said that to Bob
Woodward Bill Goldman said it wrote it
actually bill Goldman wrote all the
President's Men and everything else from
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid to
the Stepford Wives to The Princess Bride
and I know him he lives about 10 blocks
remain he's got one 12 foot high
apartment wall full of political books
and the most famous line in political
history isn't in any of them because the
guy who wrote it is sitting in front of
all the books but it's still true follow
the hundred million dollars in Russian
golf money and you know what would
really help Trump right now about this
if he had some way of proving that the
James Dodson story wasn't true or it was
misinterpreted or if a hundred million
dollars was a drop in his golf ball
bucket or if it really was just golf
money and the guys who gave it to him
you know weren't Putin spies and he
didn't agree to sell out our country for
a hundred million dollars in golf money
you know if only there was some I don't
know
tax record or tax data or tax return
that he could release to clear his good
name and stop people from connecting 100
million dollars in Russian Gulf money to
you no treason but alas I guess his tax
returns from 2014 are still under audit
so we have no way of ever seeing them so
he can't clear himself so we'll just
have to assume the worst and that the
hundred million is the tip of the
iceberg and if Trump doesn't do what
Putin wants Putin will take a lot more
than a hundred million dollars from him
follow the money and one last word for
resist peace